an inferno still rages at the antonio
guiterrez power plant the most crucial
in the country
on friday night and saturday morning the
fire had spread to a second tank
triggering a series of explosions
jose
was hosing down the second tank just
seconds before it exploded
i let go of the hose and when i started
running i got tied up in the hose and
fell on the floor but the fire engine
had already started moving away and i
held on to it
that's what got me out of there my other
colleagues couldn't get away
one firefighter has been confirmed dead
another 16 are missing
their colleagues haven't been able to
get close enough to retrieve their
bodies
over a hundred were injured president
miguel diaz-canel visited salmon
hospital over the weekend this could not
have come at a worse time for cubans who
are already living through chronic power
cuts the war in ukraine has driven up
the price of global gas and u.s
sanctions on oil tankers which were part
of the trump administration's maximum
pressure campaign against the island are
still in place driving up the cost of
energy
then there's the state of the country's
energy grid which hasn't received enough
maintenance in decades causing frequent
power blackouts
do you have power cuts several times a
week
absolutely and sometimes three times a
day
in this zone the power cuts out
frequently today we haven't had any but
yesterday we had two during the day but
you've got to adapt and see whether the
country can resolve the situation
help came from mexico and venezuela both
sending specialists helicopters and
chemicals to extinguish the flames
the support and the prevention of risks
and also help to suffocate the fire by
means of cooling with water and foam we
hope that more support will arrive soon
as well as the chemical material needed
to help us
on sunday afternoon firefighters put out
the fire in one of the supertankers
but the blaze continued in the second
tanker
late sunday night there was a huge
explosion that could be seen 50 miles
away in havana in the capital the smell
of sulfur
ed agustin
matanzas al jazeera